Now the diabolical thing
about the flu virus
is that just like the diabolical
thing about the cold virus,
you start shedding virus,
that is you are contagious
about 24 hours prior to the
onset of first symptoms for you.
So that means that you
can be a flu viral vector
even when you aren't having symptoms.
That's just the unfortunate
aspect of these viruses.
They're very clever,
they don't have brains,
but these viruses have adapted
to propagate from host to host to host.
They have a drive to
continue to stay alive
and to infect more hosts.
So even though they don't have a brain,
they have a sort of, let's
call it viral intelligence.
And as I've said several times now,
if you are still exhibiting symptoms
of the cold or flu, you are contagious.
However, with respect to the flu,
you are most contagious
during the three days when
you feel the absolute worst,
when your fever is at its worst,
when you are coughing, and
sneezing, headache, all of that,
when that is at its peak,
that is when you are most contagious.